Las Vegas Skyline changing again
recently may have gotten a glimpse of
the MSG sphere as portions of it have
been lit up for testing it will be ready
and open this fall 8 news now reporter
Brian will tells us what to expect and
Brian has a peek at the first show
coming to the venue
well yeah guys it's a beautiful day out
here and it has people asking what is
this behind me it's called the MSG Spear
and will host its first concert this
September today I looked into its
mysterious ways
it's just a great big black orb on the
skyline any idea on what it is none
whatsoever I seen it last night asking
for my window for my hotel then what'd
you think of it it looks nice this
widely ambitious entertainment venue
began in 2019 and when complete the MSG
spirit will be the largest spherical
structure in the world at 336 feet tall
and 516 feet wide construction costs for
the project have ballooned to a tune of
two billion dollars as it rises through
the skyline most people are still unsure
what it is tourists like Chris Eaton
have been visiting Las Vegas for years
and he was shocked by it that was weird
looking sort of curious I saw it online
I thought it was fake and then came in
here and see it's real I'm like all
right but not really sure what's going
to be in there or what its purpose is
going to be inside the spear will be
home to concerts shows and more it can
hold up to 20 000 guests who will be
immersed by its 106 60 000 foot
wraparound LED display and 164 000
speakers along with 4D capabilities
which means artificial wind sense and
more will surround you in your seat
outside you'll notice 580 000 foot LED
display which will light up the night
sky definitely would be something to see
if it had an option between one place
and not when I go to that one the spear
is looking to hire 3 000 employees
before it opens this fall with a
production dubbed postcard from Earth
and its first major concert U2 as its
First Act
now tickets for that YouTube concert are
not open to the public just yet but
getting a peek at the pre-sale price
ranges were anywhere between 150 and a
thousand dollars reporting near the
spear Brian will eight news now